[Musique]
ce qui témoigne sa fender
ça fait longtemps s'étaient séparés en
isère oui des burkina faso et 10h30
repart et libye par la libye a déversé
sur un gros bateau sur un bateau en
italie aux halles et vous êtes arrivés
en italie
j'imagine que là les heures ont été
difficiles sur le bateau si cette étude
difficile terrible terrible et aux étiez
combien sur ce bateau dit beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de pêcheurs
[Musique]
8-9 ans 10,4 m vous laisser et orso a
été pendu au quatrième étage de son
immeuble
voilà bon ok - j'ai vu il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont en exil mais je n'ai
pas regardé personne issue couvre de
traverser la route bancaire et traverser
la route la route voilà vous avez vu
quatre étages et il faut les escalader
quatre étages cornu bon donc moi je n'ai
rien parce yeux de montier tu vois là je
me suis beau l'asie le cours est de
monter ouais c'est ça ouais je mets là
vous avez mais vous êtes escaladeurs
professionnelle ou quoi mammouth au
solide pour vous aviez déjà escaladé
renier meubles non non non non non sur
ma première fois c'est la première fois
et vous saviez que vous risquiez votre
vie
oui tout le monde ne me dis jamais
imaginé pas passer ça je peux être
lancée les enfants voilà vous avez sauvé
voilà et on a rentré dans party mois la
serbie ce mardi mieux qu'internet rend
plus
ainsi
[Musique]
il m'a donné un cadeau à la salle